Jerome Corsi though has not backed down
instead today he filed a criminal
complaint against Robert Muller he
alleges gross misconduct by the special
prosecutor's office jerome corsi joins
us tonight to explain
of course he thank you very much for
coming on when last we spoke my
understanding was for a previous
conversation that you had made a mistake
you say you forgot the date of an email
that you forwarded and that you went and
told the special prosecutor's office
that you made that mistake and they
allowed you to amend your testimony they
allowed it but then at a later time when
you didn't say what they wanted you to
say they came back and threatened to
prosecute you for lying in the first
iteration of your testimony is that
correct yes actually and not seen by
2016 emails I hadn't reloaded the first
day of testimony I'd forgotten about two
emails when I finally loaded the time
machine I realized these emails were
there the special prosecutor allowed me
to amend the testimony about ten days
later and then in the one count they
wanted to plead guilty to they want to
charge me with knowingly and willfully
giving false information on the original
day's mistake not taking into account
that they had allowed me the special
cross prosecutor to amend the testimony
which I thought was completely
fraudulent
well it's certainly odd in most lawyers
we've spoken to have never heard of
something like that what was the point
why were they pressing you on that why
do you think they're threatening you
with perjury well from day one I mean
they blew up they said they're gonna
have enough to throw me in prison
because I forgot these emails and I I'm
convinced it was all strategy I mean I
went in to cooperate I gave my
computer's I gave my time machine I gave
handed over voluntarily my emails on my
Twitter account etcetera everything they
wanted and now the first day you know
it's a memory test and I don't get the
memory test right and suddenly I want to
be thrown in prison for the rest of my
life it's an intimidation tactic and I'm
quite convinced it's intentional
intimidating you to get you to do what
what did they want you to do that you
refused to do the key thing was that
they wanted me to be the key link
between it was gonna be me Roger stone
to me too
julian assange and then they'd have all
their collusion together it would be
Roger stone - Steve Bannon - Donald
Trump and coordination with Assange
except I figured out on my own my we'd
had 25th wedding anniversary trip to
Italy on that flight I calculated and
figured out it was Assange had Podesta's
emails I'd ever met
Assange I've never talked to a sont or
emailed him and I have no contact with
anyone who is in touch with Assange and
the rot prosecutors refused to believe
this so it led to grilling after
grilling after grilling constantly an
eight-inch thick book with my name on it
and mr. szalinski that one of the
prosecutors won't tell me if that's all
about me well tell me how he books like
that he's got and they're asking me
questions and then pulling files down
say but this email contradicts it what I
didn't don't remember that email I don't
remember in detail any of my emails had
60,000 emails in my computer for 2016
totally and and and that's kind of the
point is that they had your emails so if
you had contact with Julian Assange they
would already know it so this line is
obviously a grotesque rate so I I don't
know the standing of your criminal
complaint but in principle obviously I'm
rooting for you Jerome Corsi thank you
very much my pleasure thank you
appreciate it